recently there was a conference the 100
years starship and of course many people
came in with designs to have gigantic
fusion rockets take us to Mars and
beyond Jupiter into the into the Stars
other people said yes antimatter rockets
that's the way to go and we all had this
mental vision of the enterprise going to
the nearby star systems there is another
way to do it think of mother nature when
mother nature wants to propagate life
one possibility is a send out seeds not
just one or two but millions of seeds
most of the seeds never make it but one
or two do and as a consequence that's
how trees and forests propagate so why
not create a nano ship using
nanotechnology how big would it be some
people like Paul Davies say it could be
as big as a breadbox other people say it
could be even smaller than that why not
something the size of a needle and
because they're so small it wouldn't
take much to accelerate them to near the
speed of light realize that a very small
tabletop accelerator can accelerate
electrons to near the speed of light so
wouldn't take much for us to accelerate
nano molecules to very very fast
velocities near the speed of light using
electric fields now these probes would
be different from ordinary problems they
would be nanobots they would have the
ability to land on a hostile terrain and
create a factory just like a virus
that's what viruses do they replicate
one virus can create maybe a thousand
copies than a thousand thousand copies
and then a million billion trillion and
all of a sudden you have trillions of
these things propagating through outer
space and how would you do it one
possibility is to use the the field the
magnetic fields around Jupiter
calculations have shown that you can
whip around Jupiter using what it's
called the Faraday effect to whip
particles to perhaps near the speed of
light and again we don't have these
nanobots yet we have to wait until
nanotechnology becomes sufficiently
developed but when that happens
perhaps the hundred year starship is
gonna look like the enterprise perhaps
to look like tiny little needles by the
billions sent into outer space and maybe
only handful of them land on a distant
moon to create factories and doesn't
that sound familiar this is the plot
line of the movie 2001 remember that
gigantic obelisk on Mars that was of
Unknowing one probe a virus a
self-replicating probe that can then
explore the universe near the speed of
light